Hey there, my name is Ben, and I was just playing a little song I wrote for a Peanuts,
Earth Day special, called It’s The Small Things, Charlie Brown.
It’s about friendship, coming together and taking care of the place we call home.
I was wondering, would you like to learn a bit of the song?
Yay!
Great. Okay, let’s look at the melody here.
♪ “It’s the small things.” ♪
Simple, that is a G, A, B, back to G.
So you can do it with these three fingers if you want.
Or...
♪ “It’s the small things.” ♪
You know, when I was writing this song, something funny occurred to me.
The show is all about small things coming together to make something greater and it
really made me think of music and songs because that’s exactly how they work.
Notes coming together to make chords, and melodies. Small things becoming big things.
And that thought is going to take us right into the next part.
All right, let’s see what you got.
♪ “We come together to make big things.” ♪
Well that’s a few more notes. So maybe you want to lay your hands like this. See that?
You can start with an E. So E, D, C, B, A, C, B, A, A.
♪  “We come together to make big things.” ♪
If you don’t get it the first time, don’t worry about it.
Perhaps you should try a different approach.
You can go back and try again as much as you want to that’s what we call practice.
Now if you don’t have a piano that’s no problem, you can be the percussionist,
which is what I was when I was when I was growing up.
And a percussionist is the person who pounds on
things to keep the beat or the rhythm of the song.
Now, there are all kinds of percussion instruments.
I used to use basketballs and coffee cans ‘cause I didn’t have a drum set.
But you can snap, clap, whatever you want to do.
And when the music starts, just tap along with the beat.
I’m going to use this tambourine right here.
Hit it!
That’s great, you’re doing great. We really found our groove.
Charlie Brown, Charlie Brown, Charlie Brown!
Now I don’t know about you but I can’t wait to watch
It’s a Small Things, Charlie Brown.
I think you are going to love it.